[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je vais demander à 4 personnes pour
finir juste ici tu vois quand j'avais
mis des jeux trois autres
[Applaudissements]
non non non
ok je vais vous poser quelques questions
et je vais vous dire ce que vous devez
faire si vous êtes d'accord et si vous
n'êtes pas d'accord ok que celui qui a
déjà été intentionnelles et sa phase de
ben ok celui qui a déjà mangé un gratin
dauphinois fasse un pas en avant
celui qui n'a pas fait face en parlerait
hockey celui d'hier laban a une façade
en avant et celui qui n'aime pas en
arrière celui qui est déjà allé en
belgique phase iii bande avant celui qui
est déjà allé à mener dit tout phase 2
en arrière
ok on va s'arrêter là parce que ce qu'on
nous raconte simon cotation le but de
cet exercice c'est pour vous montrer que
si ces quatre messieurs devait faire une
course jusqu au fond noir
on s'attend à ce que ça serait jeu c'est
un qui va arriver en premier c'est
correct parce que jocelyn et devant ton
monte on est d'accord ok et que monsieur
votre monsieur benjamin va arriver en
dernier parce qu'il est tous derrière on
est d'accord
pardon a nécessairement exactement mais
il y en a qui penserait que ce serait le
cas parce que il a déjà trois pas en
avant sur monsieur benjamin simon
la dame a dit pas nécessairement c'est
tout à fait vrai parce que peut-être que
monsieur dérangement est beaucoup plus
rapide que les autres ou que je sais a
trop mangé tous fous aujourd'hui il ne
sera pas combien aussi vite que les
autres
mais les choses en fait que vu qu'il est
devant il a une longueur d'avancé sur
tous les autres et c'est comme ça la vie
en fait on se dit souvent que on
pourrait pas arriver à faire certaines
choses parce que on n'a pas aimé
certaines opportunités
parce que les autres ils ont pu faire x
ou y
celui là fait un master alors que moi je
n'ai fait que les secondaires je vis là
une famille qui est assez riche très
connecté il aura à travailler beaucoup
plus facilement que moi alors c'est pas
vrai c'est pas vrai tout est dans la
persévérance et mon sujet aujourd'hui
parce que si monsieur lange amants se
diront qu'il veut autour de lui
son but c'est de gagner la noce il veut
gagner la course
quoi qu'il arrive je vais vous parler de
mon expérience ma petite expérience de
vie
pour en arriver où je suis aujourd'hui
donc j'ai grandi ici et puis j'ai eu un
voyage et ensuite je suis revenu parce
que mon papa est décédé
et puis je devais faire des choix de vie
pour aller faire les études
universitaires au compteur donc je me
suis dit je vais partir en angleterre
mais avant de partir en angleterre et
avait d'abord décrit sujet tout le monde
connaît la blague demain sais pas qui
dit un métis moindre attaque de 26 ans
mécanicien le troisième jour j et je me
disais ça m'énerve que tout le monde et
tout le temps des préjugés sur la vie
des gens
moi je partirai moi je veux plus jamais
le jeu verront peut-être est-il déjà
arrivé à l'université
les projets j'ai une prof qui est nikos
est une qui est il repère une autre
américaine c'est 3 accent complètement
différent ce qui s'appelle donc vas-y
vos comprend donc avait des fois où
j'étais juste spectateurs debout et je
regardais je me disais ok
puis à la fois du coup je vais chercher
de trois amis qui je vais demander je
priais vos notes s'il vous plaît parce
que j'ai rien compris du tout est carré
beauté et au fur et à mesure j'ai
commencé à prendre l'habitude ça
commence à s'améliorer
et voilà un défi pour essayer certains
masters mais il me fallait trouver du
travail étant étranger il fallait avoir
un visa pour travaux visa de travail du
travail on fait comment ici bon je me
suis dit je vais d'abord trouver un
petit boulot qui va me permettre d'être
en avance et on verra ce qui va se
passer
j'étais toujours n'avait légalement donc
j'ai commencé j'ai eu un travail où je
devais répondre avec la montée les fans
pour de deux sociétés est un nouveau
challenge se pointe devant l'action dans
les clients qui
en fait vous votre absence
vous êtes décision jeudi combat d'avants
vous avez parce que vous avez un
problème vous avez pour connais pas de
gérer
j'eus un plusieurs fois klaus disent que
je suis dans le job est ce que vraiment
je dois faire ça du confort et du temps
leurs marques
peut-être que je devrais changer les
choses et où tu fais ton travail cit a
été engagée
j'ai continué j'ai continué j'ai kiffé
et puis après une ouverture pour un
[Musique]
gestionnaire de projet de la même
société et toute la compagnie tout ce
qui était au téléphone ont fait
l'application a plus ou moins 300
personnes en est
la vie comme elle est belle j'ai eu une
dure j'étais la seule à l'avoir
et puis je me suis dit allez je vais
faire de mon mieux pour pouvoir avancer
mais il y avait quelque chose qui me
rappelait vers l'afrique
ça a toujours été comme ça pourquoi je
sais pas pourquoi puisque peut-être que
je me dis qu'il ya tellement de choses à
faire ici je suis d'ici et que je
pourrai apporter tellement beaucoup de
chose à mon pays
donc j'ai décidé de revenir et en
revenant c'était encore pas facile pour
moi de pouvoir y arriver parce que il
fallait avoir une certaine expérience
par rapport au domaine dans lequel je
cherchais du travail
j'ai fait du bénévolat pendant quelques
mois
et puis je vais rencontrer des gens
comme madame lydia dit essayer de vous
entourer de gens qui vont vous permettre
d'avancer sans pour autant abandonner
j'ai eu à faire des rencontres j'ai eu à
voir des gens qui ont cru en moins et
puis j'ai travaillé dans le domaine des
recherches scientifiques
de fil en aiguille aujourd'hui je suis
dans le secteur pétrolier donc en fait
le but de montaut aujourd'hui c'est de
dire plus aux jeunes qui sont encore en
train de faire leurs études
universitaires ou bien ceux qui viennent
tout juste de finir ça sert à rien de se
dire que vous n'allez pas y arriver que
vos rêves ne vont pas être réalisés ou
quoi que ce soit parce que vous n'avez
pas une ceci parce que c'est même cela
en fait cette vie est tellement bien en
fait qu'on a tous les mêmes chances
d'une manière ou d'une autre
peut-être qu'aujourd'hui vous n'allez
pas le voir mais si vous avons donné
j'avais vous n'allez vous devez toujours
persévérer toujours on dit que l'endroit
le plus riche sur tmc le cimetière parce
qu'il ya tellement de talents gâchés qui
ont des intérêts il ya tellement de gens
qui auraient pu faire beaucoup plus que
ce qu'ils ont fait lors de leur vivant
et que voilà maintenant c'est gâcher
donc jeudi un nouveau encourager chaque
personne
en se disant c'est pas mal ce
qu'aujourd'hui vous envoyer une
application on vous dit non tu finis en
envoyer 500 on vous dira tout à la fois
toujours continuer si ça fonctionne un
moment essayé de changer de stratégie
c'est d'innover maintenant il ya encore
beaucoup plus de facilités parce qu'on a
accès à la technologie
on a accès à beaucoup de gens que l'on
peut rencontrer comme le thé tôt
qu'aujourd'hui merci aux organisateurs
d'ailleurs parce que c'est aussi une
opportunité pour vous de rencontrer des
gens de leur dire qui vous êtes
parce que chacun a un talent caché un
talent inné tu n'attends que de sortir
nous pend dupuis sortir vous devez faire
quelque chose et il faut persévérer faut
pas abandonner nous voilà mon message
aujourd'hui
[Applaudissements]